my mind's going blank now what's the
song
that is played where everybody is on the
chair everybody uh you know
what i can't remember it i think it's a
mitch hedberg joke or uh or a jack handy
joke now that when when i go i want to
go like my grandfather did peacefully in
his sleep not like the passengers in his
car screaming
[Applause]
but his poll numbers have been
absolutely cratering now they're
cratering for basically one specific
reason and then one general reason so
the specific reason is because of
afghanistan the general reason is
because joe biden is a house plant so he
was elected because he was a house plant
right but he was a house plant who's
supposed to provide stability the thing
about house plans is that they are
barely alive they cover the water stain
and they don't move around a lot you
don't have to worry about the house
plant you leave the house for the for
work in the morning you come back the
house plants in exactly the same place
maybe it's grown a little bit that's
pretty much it
but joe biden elected as a house plant
is actually turning out to be the plant
from a little shop of horrors right he's
eating everything else he's in terms of
policy he's very much alive even though
in terms of sentience he is not and so
if you voted for joe biden or if you are
somebody in the middle who's kind of
warm to joe biden you're kind of getting
the worst of both worlds you're getting
the non-sentient non-charismatic
president but he's not like obama in any
of the areas of charisma or magnetism or
personal draw and you're getting the
radical policy of barack obama except on
steroids because actually joe biden's
policies are way more radical than
barack obama's were at this point even
in his presidency and obama was really
radical on policy this early on in his
presidency
and so every time joe biden now appears
and seems to be doddering his way
through a press conference it hurts him
rather than helping him if he were a
moderate and he was dottering his way
through people would be willing to say
that that's kind of a feature not a bug
all right he's daughtering but the
reason he's doddering is because we
elected somebody to daughter the whole
point is we wanted somebody who moved
slowly incrementally somebody who is not
going to be threatening but if he's
threatening and also daughtering now it
just seems like things are spinning out
of control and so every press conference
that he has where he seems incapable of
holding it together is a serious problem
for him that's why the afghanistan
debacle made so clear that he is is just
not in control right even when he makes
a call those calls are so incapable of
meeting with any sort of good policy
that this seems like an administration
where the brakes have been taken off and
you literally have an octogenarian in
charge of the car driving directly at a
crowd
and everybody's kind of freaking out
about that which means that if you're a
moderate on the fence if you're joe by a
joe manchin or if you're a christian
cinema you're like i don't want to be in
this cloud in this car the future of
this car is not good
okay so let's go to the the daughtering
of joe biden and then we'll get to the
policy of joe biden so when it comes to
the daughtering of joe biden he um he
just continues to lie and around
it really is not good for him all of
these things add up like the way that
that people make decisions about
politicians typically is that over and
over and over their preconceived notions
about those politicians are either
rejected or reinforced joe biden every
day is reinforcing the fact that he is
not with us that he is not with us
that his policies are radical and he's
not in control that this is a car
careening out of control no brakes
octogenarian at the wheel who should
have had his license revoked at least
five years ago here was joe biden
yesterday he was doing a a
kind of meet and greet
with a uh with a bunch of ju so-called
jewish leaders i say so-called because a
lot of the jewish leaders that he was
meeting with aren't particularly jewish
in any sort of
religious sense and they kind of lead
reconstructionist synagogues that don't
reflect any of the principles of the
torah uh they're not particularly
interested in jewish philosophy but put
that aside joe biden is speaking to them
and he starts just telling lies about
visiting the tree of life synagogue it
turns out that he did not the tree of
life synagogue of course was the site of
the white supremacist shooting a couple
of years ago and uh he said he visited
he he absolutely did not he's just
making things up
i remember
spending time
at the you know
going to uh
the you know the tree of life synagogue
speaking with them
just it's just as amazing these things
are happening
happening in america
okay and then he started daughtering
through a story about his daughter's
wedding he couldn't remember what was
going on it's very awkward i mean it's
your grandpa is wandering off script
now it's it's
reminiscent i think it's a mitch hedberg
joke or uh or a jack handy joke you know
that when i go i i want to go like my
grandfather did peacefully in his sleep
not like the passengers in his car
screaming
that's that's the democratic party at
this point right here's joe biden again
kind of wandering off script into the
cornfield
my daughter
married a jewish young man
and i you know dream of every
every every
catholic father that she married a
jewish doctor but uh all kind of aside
he did is a great surgeon and they
played and i'm my mind's going blank now
what's the song that is played where
everybody is on the chair everybody uh
you know
what i can't remember it anyway
and that's the song was played
so you know i don't know what the hell
is going on here
inspiring stuff there from the president
of the united states very very very
inspiring stuff and then he added on top
of this he says you know he starts
talking about never again
now this is where you move from the
senile to the
rather unforgivable here's joe biden
talking about never again which of
course is verbiage that is used
surrounding the holocaust that we as the
world will never allow this sort of
stuff to happen again
i have some questions for joe biden
about this particular perspective coming
out of his face his daughtering old
collapsing face here's the presidents of
the united states
i guess the point i want to make is that
it just shows that
if we walk away from never again
it's going to happen again
it can't happen again
and so
i guess the point i'm making is that the
attack in pittsburgh those attacks
all anti-semitic attacks aren't just a
strike against the jewish community
they're a strike against the soul of our
nation
okay i'm just going to point out when he
says we can't tell never again to happen
this is the same president who is
currently attempting to deal with the
genocidal iranian regime to allow them a
pathway to nuclear weapons
okay this is the same president of the
united states who's currently talking
about opening a palestinian consulate in
jerusalem reopening the wounds of a
process that has completely failed and
incentivizing terror attacks in the
region against jews
this is the same president of the united
states who on another front you want to
talk about never again just abandon 38
million people to today's nazis the
taliban who are literally gonna go
around just murdering everybody they
don't like this is already happening in
afghanistan right now this is the same
president who's been making kind
overtures to china which has become
increasingly aggressive meanwhile
holding in shenzhen one million uyghur
muslims in concentration camps so when
this guy says i'm anti uh you know never
again means something to me no it
doesn't it absolutely 100 is not it's a
bunch of words that he thinks he has to
say in front of you and here's the thing
he has no credibility on these issues he
just doesn't
his own administration has completely
afghanistan is a perfect case in point
he literally just said we're for human
rights when we have to say thing about
it say things about it but when we
actually have to you know do something
basic like leaving 2 500 troops there
with no no actual combat casualties in a
support role then i won't do that he is
so unwilling to stand up for human
rights i mean don't don't talk the
language of human rights if you are
literally unwilling to make even the
most minute sacrifices on behalf of
human rights
and not just human rights by the way
american interests in afghanistan but as
long as he's going to be saying never
again
you know there's a lot there's in the
jewish community there's been talk for
decades about why it was that the allies
didn't bomb the rail lines uh during the
holocaust why didn't they why why didn't
the allies you know send a few planes
and just bomb the rail lines that were
connecting
various cities to the concentration
camps and the defense has always been it
was the middle of a war you have to use
those bombs where they are best utilized
namely against nazi troops in more
strategically necessary areas that's an
open argument historically speaking
okay but here we are not even talking
about even that kind of sacrifice we are
talking about
the united states of america leaving in
place
people who are already there doing the
things they were already doing to
prevent people from being shot in the
face for walking in the street without a
veil and joe biden wasn't even willing
to do that
so no i'm not particularly interested in
hearing about never again from this
doofus it's just
his credibility is shocked it's shot
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content